there are new revelations about the
meeting between Donald Trump jr. and a
group of Russians last year Donald Trump
jr. admits it was to seek potentially
damaging information on the Clinton
campaign but just who attended the
meeting continues to change now a
prominent Russian American lobbyist and
one-time Soviet military officer has
admitted he too was at the meeting which
was also attended by President Trump's
son
the former Trump campaign chairman the
president's son-in-law a Russian lawyer
and the music publicist who set up the
meeting the president is spending the
weekend at his New Jersey golf course
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president after returning from Paris
Friday President Trump waved two LPGA
guests at his bed minster golf course in
New Jersey but as he spends another
weekend away from Washington his
administration is reeling from
continuing revelations as it relates to
the Russia investigations reportedly yet
another Russian attended the now
infamous get-together at Trump Tower
with Donald Trump jr. and senior
campaign staff last year The Associated
Press says are not Achmed chin a Russian
American with suspected links to Russian
intelligence also attended the meeting
with Natalia vessel net skaia
a Russian lawyer as far as this
incidents concerned this is all of it is
everything our Commission's presence
contradicts statements from the
president's son earlier this week that
there were no additional attendees nor
topics discussed other than adoption and
potential dirt on Hillary Clinton it
also raises questions about how much
then Canada Trump knew while visiting
the French president in Paris this week
mr. Trump defended the meeting
nothing happened from the meeting zero
happened from the meeting and honestly I
think the press made a very big deal
over something that really a lot of
people would do CBS News has also
learned that senior adviser and
son-in-law Jared Kushner revised his
security clearance paperwork twice most
recently to reflect the Trump Tower
meeting Krishnas attorney said he was
not introduced to others while there
and said the disclosure is not legally
required Russian specialist Jeffrey man
call being reached out to by
representatives of the Russian
government or intelligence services
should certainly spark red flags and
prompt occulta to the FBI
Errol Barnett reporting from New Jersey